NICOLA MARZARI: To calculate
ensemble averages--
that is to calculate
thermodynamical properties.
And we have seen
also a few movies
on how we can calculate
reaction barriers
and how we can follow in
real time chemical kinetics.
The last application
of molecular dynamics
is likely more different.
In particular, one can
use a final temperature,
classic in molecular dynamics,
as an optimization scheme.
In general, suppose that you
have a complex potential energy
surface.
This is obviously
in one dimension,
but you could
think this as being
in a multi-dimensional space.
And actually, your
potential energy function
could represent a
complex cost function.
Again, it could be,
say, the problem
of optimizing the
usage of your planes
on several routes for
one airline company.
And obviously, depending on
where you put your planes,
you have a certain cost.
And so this cost function
tends to be very complex
depending on your coordinates,
how you arrange your planes.
And finding either the
global minimum or sort of one
of the lowest minima can
be a very complex affair.
And one of the
powerful techniques
that has been introduced
in the early '80s
is something called a
simulated annealing.
That is basically a
technique that basis itself
on a thermodynamical analogy.
That is suppose that you
want to find this minimum.
And if you were to use
a deterministic recipe,
it would be very
difficult. You would
start from a certain
point and then
go down according
to the gradient
until you end up in what
would be a local minima.
And so what, in particular,
Kilpatrick, Gelatt, and Vecchi
introduced was a thermodynamical
technique in which you really
populate your phase space
with what we call walkers.
So these are sort of
dynamical systems.
So those are the
points that represent
those dynamical systems.
You give them some coordinates.
That is they are going to
have some potential energy.
And then you give
them some temperature.
So they are going to
have some kinetic energy.
You can think this
as a swarm of skiers
sort of going around
your phase space.
And if you have a lot
of them and if these
have a lot of temperature, they
will move all over phase space.
But by the time you start
sort of very slowly cooling
this dynamical systems down,
you start removing temperature
for them, they are going
to condensate really
in whichever local
minima they find.
So some of them may
end up, say, here.
And you cool them
down, and slowly they
find themselves here.
But if you cool them
sufficiently slow--
and really in order to make
this into an exact schema,
you have to pull them
almost infinitely slowly.
So it's never going to be
an exact approach, but just
a stochastic approach.
But, you know, with some luck,
you'll find that some of them
start condensing in
interesting minima.
And then you choose basically
your lowest minima possible.
And this is actually a very
sort of practical and useful
approach.
And so it's sort
of fairly widely
used in optimization problems.
OK, so this sort of
concludes the sort
of set of applications
of molecular dynamics.
Now, I wanted to
sort of hint at some
of the advanced statistical
mechanics techniques
that you'll actually see later
in the class that, generally
speaking, go under the umbrella
name of Green-Kubo techniques.
And sort of I'm taking
one of the simplest
examples in which, actually,
Albert Einstein was involved.
So it's an interesting approach.
Well, this has to do on starting
a macroscopic property that
is really diffusion in a solid.
So you could think
of a silicon crystal.
And we are doping that silicon
with gallium or phosphorus,
and so you are
interested in studying
how the impurities in
this system move around.
And so if you
want, what you have
is that you have a perturbation.
You put a sort of gallium
on the surface of silicon,
and then this diffuses
into the solid.
And sort of the general
Green-Kubo approach
is a formalism that relates
some of these macroscopic
properties, like a
diffusion coefficient,
a transpose property, to
microscopic properties.
And you'll see that as sort of
fluctuations of the equilibrium
distribution.
OK.
So suppose that we are looking
at the diffusion of, again,
something like
gallium and silicon.
What you would define as your
sort of fundamental variable
is the concentration
of impurities.
So that's a sort of
four-dimensional function is
a concentration function
of the [INAUDIBLE] space
you are interested
and function of time.
And then, obviously,
there is sort
of the diffusion
law for this that
says that basically
the current is
really proportional to the
gradient of the concentration.
And then you put this together
with a sort of continuity
equation that tells you that the
derivative of the concentration
with respect to time plus the
divergence of your current--
that is your flux--
needs to be constant.
That equals-- let's say
it's going to be equal to 0.
I mean, this very
simply says that,
if an infinitesimal volume
the concentration changes,
it's that because there
is a current going out
of that infinitesimal volume.
And so the divergence of
the current measures this.
And with fixed diffusion law,
we can put the 2 and 2 together
and basically obtain this
relation, this differential
equation, for the
concentration profile in time.
So if you want,
these are starting
macroscopic relationship.
And then what
becomes interesting
is the derivation that
Einstein did in order
to recover the connection
with the microscopic dynamics.
And this is just a little
bit of algebra, which
I will go over fairly quickly.
But, basically, what
we are doing here,
we are actually
multiplying the left term
and the right-hand
terms by r square
and integrating
it over all space.
And once we do
that, well, what we
have is that on the
right-hand side,
this requires some calculus.
So I won't go really
into the derivation.
But by sort of
integration by parts,
you can actually show that
this integral provided,
say, the concentration
is normalized to 1
when integrated in all
space, what we really obtain
is just 2 times the
dimensionality of your problem.
That is, if you are in one
dimension, sort of small d
is going to be equal to 1.
If you are in two
dimensions, it's
going to be equal to 2, to
3, and so on and so forth.
So this integral
really just gives us
the dimension of the space.
And again, we won't go
into how we prove this.
What we have on the left-hand
side, on the contrary,
is really, you see, the
average value of r square.
What we mean by this
bracket that you see
is the integral
over all space of r
square with the probability.
If you want the
concentration, it's
identical to the
probability of having
a certain particle in a certain
position in a certain time.
So what this integral
means is really
the average value over
all space of r square,
how much your
particles has moved.
And we have the
derivative and the time.
And so you see we
start seeing somehow
a connection between a
diffusion coefficient
that's the macroscopic property
and the microscopic properties,
the dynamic piece, how much
the particles are moving
once you put them in somewhere.
Let me actually
give you an example
of what would this
quantity look like
and how we would calculate it in
a molecular dynamic simulation.
Again, you can think
of your gallium atoms
being at the surface.
At the beginning, you
put everything in motion.
And they are going to move
with a sort of random walk
towards the inside.
And if you want to calculate
this sort of average value
of what is called the
mean square displacement,
the average value
of r square, well,
you need really to do the
average over all your particle
at a certain time
of delta r square.
Delta r square is really how far
all these particles have moved.
And you know, this
would look at something
like this in a
typical, say, solid.
Actually, the example
that I have here
is slightly more exotic, but
it was a sort of good example
to show you the difference
between a liquid and a solid.
And it's the case
of silver iodide
that is, in particular,
an ionic crystal
in which the blue iodine
atoms sit on a BCC lattice.
And for each iodine,
there is a silver atom.
But above, say, 420
Kelvin, this system
is in a very peculiar
state of matter, what
is called a super ionic state
in which this iodine atom
oscillates around an
equilibrium position exactly
as atoms do in a solid, while
the silver atoms sort of move
around exactly like a liquid.
So it's a system
that is really solid.
It's crystalline.
But one sublattice,
the silver sublattice,
is sort of moving
around as a liquid.
And so if you calculate what
are the average mean square
displacements-- that
is if you average, say,
all the iodine atoms, what is
their average delta r squared,
how much they move around--
well, you'll discover
that really, in a sense,
that they are a
crystalline solid.
They are just going to oscillate
around their equilibrium
position.
And so you calculate
that average.
During a molecular
dynamic simulation,
you see there is a sort
of first very short period
of thermalization.
The atoms start
moving, but then they
are just oscillating around.
They are not going anywhere.
So their instantaneous
mean squared displacement
as a value that is
just a constant.
So this is sort of typical
of a crystalline solid.
If you do the same
thing for the silvers,
you see that, as a function
of increase in temperature,
you see, at 250 Kelvin below
the superionic transition, also
the silvers sort of look
more or less flatter.
But when you increase
the temperature,
their mean square
displacement starts becoming
a linear function of time.
So the silvers are
really moving around.
They are diffusing
away as a liquid.
And so in the mean
square displacement,
you can see the
signature of a liquid
when they increase
linearly with time.
Or you can see the
signature of a solid
where they just are
not going anywhere.
They just vibrate around
the equilibrium position.
And so this is the
quantity that we
could calculate in a
molecular dynamic simulation.
The average of the mean
square displacement,
I have written it here.
Remember, this is going to be
equal to 2 times the diffusion
coefficient times the
dimensionality of your system.
And now, we sort of work
a little bit with this.
And in particular, we
introduce this sort
of alternative definition of
the displacement of an atom.
This is actually very useful.
If you are sort of working in
periodic boundary conditions,
you need to be careful.
Often, your molecular dynamics
codes, for simplicity,
always show you the
coordinates of the ions
as they were sitting in
your first unit cells.
If an atom is
diffusing as a liquid
and it sort of moves
around and from one cell
moves in the second unit
cell, your code usually
will actually sort
of bring it back
by a lattice translation
in the first unit cell.
So a universal way to
sort of take into account
what the actual
position of an atom is
is actually write the
position that is usually
a vector that satisfies this
periodic boundary condition
as an integral of the velocity.
So in that sense, the
position of your particle
is always taking correctly
into account all the distance
that has been traversed.
So if you have a
unit cell really
and your particle
is moving, you'll
sort of integrate
correctly your trajectory
by doing the integral of
the velocity, while sort
of your algorithm would actually
bring back the particle once it
crosses a boundary.
OK.
Nothing deep here,
we are just sort
of writing the position as
the integral of the velocity.
But with this definition,
we can actually
go back and look at
what is the expression
for the average of the
mean square displacement.
That is the delta x square.
And now, we write it
actually as the square
of the integral of the
velocity at the instant of t.
And so I'm just sort of writing
this integral out explicitly
when I sort of
expand the square.
I have an integral
in t and t prime.
And again, the bracket means
just the ensemble average
on all your particles, so it
commutes with the integral.
And so what we are
calculating here
is really the sum over all the
particles and averaging that.
That is dividing by the
total number of particles
of the velocity at certain
instant t prime times
the velocity of a
certain instant t2 prime.
And we can actually, for
computational convenience,
this is really an
integral on a square,
integral from 0 to t in one
dimension and the integral
from 0 to t in the
other dimension.
But this expression
is symmetrical.
So we can actually integrate
this only on half the square.
We are integrating it
only on the triangle.
If this is were t and t prime
and our integration interval
in this, we can just
sort, for simplicity,
integrate into half of this.
OK.
So what we have
achieved here is we
have written this
average mean squared
displacement as an integral
of the average product
between the velocity
at a certain instant
and the velocity at
a different instant.
And this is sort of where our
connection with the equilibrium
properties is
starting to emerge.
And you'll see this in a moment.
This is called velocity
autocorrelation function.
And I'm writing it
more explicitly.
All of this has been done, again
to keep the algebra simple,
in two dimensions.
So remember, the
Einstein relation.
Sorry, we are in one dimension.
So remember, the
Einstein relation.
The small d, the dimensionality
of your system, is 1.
So we have the 2 times
the diffusion coefficient
is equal to the derivative of
the mean square displacement.
And mean square
displacement in itself
has been written as
the double integral.
But when you take the
derivative with respect to t,
one of the integral cancels out.
So if you want, this
is our final relation.
Let me actually sort
of write it over here
and remove the factor of 2.
We have the diffusion
coefficient as
written as this integral.
We can sort of exploit the
translational invariance
in time.
Really, if we are
looking at what
is the average value of
the product of the velocity
at a certain instant, d
prime, times the velocity
of another instant d2 prime,
well, that average product
is not going to be different
if we translate it in time.
So we can refer it to
an arbitrary origin.
And so we just do a
translation in which we shift
d2 prime into 0 and so on.
So this is sort of
our final expression.
And this is what is
called a velocity-velocity
autocorrelation function.
So you see, what we have is
that the macroscopic property,
the diffusion coefficient,
that is really
telling you how a system
responded to a perturbation.
You put some gallium on
your surface of silicon,
and then there is this
macroscopic diffusion transfer
process.
That is there is a perturbation,
and the system evolves.
It can actually be
related to an equilibrium
property of the system.
That is really,
ultimately, what are
the mean square displacements,
how atom microscopically move
around.
And in particular, the
quantity that is playing here
is this velocity-velocity
autocorrelation.
You see, what this is
looking at is suppose
that you have a velocity
at a certain instant.
And then you look
at that instant
that is sort of tau away in time
from sort of your instant 0.
And you look at the product
of these two velocities.
Now, if tau is very
small, the velocity
is not going to have
changed very much.
So in the limit of small
tau, your velocity at 0
and your velocity at tau are
going to be very similar.
So if you want, there
is a lot of correlation.
When you take this
product, it's going
to look a lot like v0 squared.
And then all these things
are normalized properly.
So it could look like 1.
But as you sort of
move away in time,
you go towards longer
and longer times,
there is going to
be no correlation.
Your velocity at 0
and your velocity
at an instant that is
very far away in time
is not going to be correlated.
And so the product of this can
be, if you want, any number.
And when you take
the average, you
see the sort of ensemble
average, the bracket.
When you average this
quantity on all your particles
in the system,
this is just going
to be 0 because
this thing can have
any positive or negative value.
Because there is no correlation
between the velocity
at the large tau.
And so this thing
is going to be 0.
OK.
So the limit of this
velocity-velocity
autocorrelation for very large
tau is going to be equal to 0.
The limit for sort of very small
tau is going to be equal to 1
or whatever your
normalization factor is.
And then there should be
some interesting structure
at a certain time.
And we'll see it
in a moment that
suppose your system is
actually sort of oscillating.
You are looking not
at the liquid part
of your silver iodide,
but you are looking just
at the sort of
crystalline iodine
sort of oscillating around.
Well, suppose that your iodine
atom has a certain period
of oscillation.
So it sort of keeps
going back and forth.
Well, then there will
be a lot of correlation
if you look at your
velocity at a time 0
and your velocity
at an instant that
is roughly equal to a
period of oscillation.
Because if this thing
were to oscillate exactly
around this equilibrium,
every sort of period
you would have that the
velocity has become the same.
OK.
So you will see a very
definite structure
in this correlation function.
If your system is not a
crystal, if your system is
sort of diffusing away as a
liquid, as your time increases,
the correlation becomes 0.
And even if it's a crystal,
but it's not really
oscillating perfectly,
like a harmonic
oscillator around the
period, when you really
got to very, very
long time away,
you start losing this
correlation that sort of takes
place at every beta.
And that average quantity
starts in itself to be 0.
So how does our
velocity-velocity
autocorrelation
function looks like?
Well, it looks like
something like this.
I need to sort of graph it here.
So again, when you are really
sort of far away in time--
so, you know, what
we are plotting
is the ensemble average
of vdt times vf0.
So very, very far away in
time, it's going to be 0.
There is no correlation between
the velocity of the atoms.
At very, very small times, there
is really maximum correlation.
And then what is
in between really
depends on the
dynamics of the system.
And it can look very different
in different systems.
But Einstein relation and
the Green-Kubo formula
that we have seen
before actually
relates, first of all,
the integral from 0
to infinity of the expansion
to the diffusion coefficient.
So again, these functions
really represent
a [INAUDIBLE]
microscopic fluctuation
at equilibrium, sort of how the
velocities are correlated, so
how your vibrate around.
But all the sort of
algebra we have seem before
shows also that the
integral of this quantity
gives you the diffusion
coefficient [INAUDIBLE]..
And that's one way of
calculating the diffusion
coefficient.
The other way, if you
go back to your slides,
would be just calculating
the derivative with respect
to time of the mean
squared displacement.
And so in a liquid,
you have seen
that your mean square
displacements sort of become
linear if you sort of weighed
enough time with respect
to time.
And so the diffusion coefficient
is also equivalently given
by the slope of this system.
One of the interesting
things that you
obtain from the sort
of velocity-velocity
autocorrelation function
that you don't obtain
from the slope of your
mean square displacement
is that you can obtain what
we call the power spectrum.
That is you can look at
a system like a liquid
and figure out what are
the typical vibrations
in your system.
Again, this is because, you
know, what we have said.
If a system, if an atom,
is oscillating around, say,
an equilibrium
position, there is going
to be a lot of correlation.
That is, if we look at time 0
and if you look after a period
t, the velocities are, again,
going to be very similar.
If you look again at
time 2t, they are, again,
going to be similar.
If you look at the time
3t, they are, again,
going to be similar.
So in the velocity-velocity
autocorrelation function,
actually you will see not
only a peak at 0, but a peak
at t, at 2t, and 3t and so on,
and then sort of slowly decay.
But so that means that
the velocity-velocity
autocorrelation function
will sort of show somehow
some periodic features
that are related
to what is the typical
dynamics of your particles.
And so if you do the Fourier
transform of that, the Fourier
transform of a
function, it picks up
what are the relevant
frequencies in that function.
And so if you do
that, you actually
find out that what is
the vibrational density
of states, what are the typical
frequencies of your system.
And this is sort
of an example that
comes from a molecular
dynamics simulation of water.
So what you have is you
have your liquid water.
Remember, that in a
system like liquid water,
you actually need only 30, 40,
50 molecules in a unit cell
to basically simulate the
infinite system as long as you
are sort of enough far away
from the melting or freezing
transition.
So you take the system,
you let it evolve.
And then you calculate at
every instant in time t
the product of the velocity.
You average that on
all the molecules,
and you have the
velocity-velocity
autocorrelation function.
And that, as a
function of time, will
show typical beatings that
have to do with the frequencies
in your system.
You do the Fourier
transform of this,
and you find a power spectrum.
You find a vibrational spectrum
of your liquid in which you see
you can identify
a very large peak,
a very sort of typical set of
vibrations that have really
to do-- this is actually heavy
water, so it's got deuterium--
with the stretching mode of
the deuterium oxygen distance
in the water molecule, so the
modes in which the two atoms
vibrate one against the other.
So this would be the optical
intermolecular modes.
And then you see
another peak that
has to do with the
vibration modes, the fact
that the water molecules
act as a scissors.
And then you find a lot
of lower energy modes.
But again, just the
Fourier transform
of this velocity-velocity
autocorrelation function
gives you right away what is the
vibrational density of states
and, again, sort of
a snapshot of what
are the important
vibrations in the system.
And a lot of
spectroscopic properties
would be correlated with this
vibrational density of states.
Because suppose that
some of these states
are, say, what we
call infrared active.
That is, when the
atoms move around,
they create a
little polarization.
They create a little
local electric field.
Well, then those
modes would interact
and couple very
strongly with sort
of electromagnetic radiation.
And so depending
on your frequency
of your electromagnetic
radiation,
you would couple
very strongly with
the appropriate frequencies
of your liquid system.
And so this is, again, one
of the sort of very important
quantities that you
might want to extract
from a molecular
dynamics simulation.
And if, instead of having a
liquid, you had a solid, again,
that would be the sort
of vibrational density
of states of your phonon modes.
OK.
This sort of concludes
this parenthesis
on Green-Kubo approach.
You'll see more of this in
one of the later classes.
But again, if there is one
thing that you need to remember,
it's this, that this general
sort of set of relation
make a connection between
a macroscopic property
and, in particular, a response
property of the system.
The diffusion coefficient
is a response property
of the system to a
concentration inhomogeneity.
And these macroscopic property,
these response properties,
can be connected to equilibrium
fluctuations or something
like the velocity-velocity
autocorrelation function.
And there are a lot of
interesting quantities
that you can obtain from
Green-Kubo relations
besides the diffusion
coefficient.
So in particular,
you could find out
the viscosity of your system.
Suppose that you want to study
liquid iron because you want
to understand how
seismic waves propagate
in this sort of liquid
inner core of Earth.
Well, you are very interested
in the viscosity of the system
because you want to know how
sort of shear propagation
takes place.
And just from the fluctuations
in the stress tensor,
if you have your unit cell
with all the iron liquid atoms
moving around, the
fluctuations instantaneous
due to the thermal motion
in the stress tensor
for that system give
you the sheer viscosity.
Or say you want to
study how, say, one
of the systems like
water would couple
and what would be its
infrared absorption.
Well, you can actually look at
the instantaneous fluctuations
in the total polarization
in the system.
Because what is the microscopic
local electric field there
and how it couples?
So again, you can sort of find
out macroscopic properties
from microscopic
fluctuation or sort
of electrical thermal
conductivities.
Again, sort of macroscopic
transfer properties
can be found out
from fluctuations
in the autocorrelation
functions for the sort
of electrical charge or a
thermal carriers in a system.
OK.
This basically concludes the
classical molecular dynamic
part.
And what I wanted
to show you next
is how we actually do first
principle molecular dynamics.
That is how we sort of
evolve atoms in time
not using a classic
field, but using
our favorite electronic
structure methods.
That, actually for
most of this class,
has been density
functional theory,
but doesn't really have to
be density functional theory.
Any of the electronic
structure methods would work.
Density functional theory tends
to be the simplest and most
efficient to implement.
Sadly, in order
to do this, I need
to give you some other reminders
of formal classical mechanics.
Because especially in first
principle molecular dynamics,
we use a lot of the concept
of extended Lagrangian and
extended Hamiltonians.
That is we'll derive
the equation of motion
from an appropriate functional
that includes sometimes very
exotic degrees of freedom.
So let me remind
you how you have
seen this in some of your
physics or mechanics class.
But let me show you
how, in general, one
can think at evolution
in phase space
and sort of find
out the equations
that integrated the trajectory.
And up to now, we
have really just seen
Newton equation
of motion, forces
equal to the mass
times acceleration.
But there is a sort of more
complex and, if you want,
more elegant formalism to
derive the equation of motion
for a system.
And in particular,
what I'm showing here
is sort of what is called
Lagrangian dynamics.
In fact, this is actually
very, very simple.
And the way Lagrangian
dynamics works is this.
First of all, you have to
construct your Lagrangian.
That is the
functional that drives
the evolution of your systems.
And there are various ways
in which one of constructs
these functionals.
And there are even sort
of equivalent ways.
One can construct
different Lagrangians
that give you the same
equation of motion
of the same trajectories.
But, see, what is important
here is the standard way.
That is the way we
construct this functional,
it's not very different
from thermodynamics.
We just take the kinetic
energy of the system,
T. We subtract the potential
energy of the system.
And this is sort of our
Lagrangian, T minus V.
In general, the potential
energy, as you have seen it,
tends to be a function
of position only.
So usually, we
written as a function
of, if we have n
particles, r1 to rn.
So you know, this is what is
called a conservative field.
If you are sort of
a particle living
in a gravitational
field, well, you
are going to be in
a certain position.
You are going to feel
a certain potential,
or you are going to
feel a certain force.
That's the gradient
of that potential.
You go somewhere else, you'll
feel a different potential.
You see a different force.
And the work that you sort of
make in going from one place
to the other, it's just
the integral of that force.
And it's independent
of the trajectory.
So this is sort of, you
know, a very general sort
of potential function
that you have seen.
And you know, again, the
kinetic energy, you have seen it
and tends to be a function of
the square of the velocities.
OK.
So again, if you have
only one particle,
its kinetic energy is
going to be 1/2 times
the mass times the
square velocity.
We usually, in the
Lagrangian formulation,
don't use the sort of notation
for the positions r1, rn.
But instead, say
in particular, we
use the other notation in
which the coordinates are
given by q1, q2, qn.
And then the velocities we
just indicate them as q dot.
And the reason we call them
q is that what you sometimes
want to do is not use
your regular coordinates
as the description
of your position
for your dynamical
system, but you might want
to use generalized coordinates.
Say you study water molecules.
And all of a sudden you want to
describe this liquid of water
molecules as rigid molecules.
So you want to
say that the angle
between the hydrogen,
oxygen, and the hydrogen
doesn't change.
And if you want to say that the
distance between the hydrogen
and oxygen doesn't
change, well, then you
want to sort of develop
a dynamic in which what
you really move around are
not the position of the atoms,
but you move around
the center of mass
of your water molecules.
And you move around
the orientation.
This is actually very important.
If you remember in
sort of last class,
I've told you that, when
we study water, actually
because water at
regular temperature
is still a quantum
system, is still
a system that has most
of its vibrational states
frozen in the sort of 0
point motion quantum state,
you actually tend to
describe better liquid water
if you describe it as a set of
rigid molecules moving around.
This is, again,
an approximation.
But it's actually a
better approximation
of the true dynamics of the
system than an approximation
which you let also the internal
degrees of freedom change.
So suppose you want
to sort of simulate
the rigid water around.
You need to find out what
are the equation of motion
for this generalized
set of coordinates
in which what you really move
around when you move water
is the center of mass
and their orientation.
And you know, it would
be very difficult to do
sort of using Newton's equation
of motion with a constraint.
And so what you do, you use
your Lagrangian formulation
in a generalized formalism
of generalized coordinates q
and generalized velocity q dot.
So what Lagrangian
dynamics tell us
is that we construct our
Lagrangian function T
minus V. And then the equation
of motion are given by these.
These are the
Lagrangian equation.
We want to derive them, but
this is how they are written.
The derivative with respect to
time of the partial derivatives
of the Lagrangian with respect
to the generalized velocity q
dot minus the partial
derivatives of the Lagrangian
with respect to the
generalized coordinates
needs to be equal to 0.
And you know, this
also focuses us
on just constructing
the two scalar
function, kinetic energy and
potential energy, for a system.
And that is just, you
know, straightforward
algebra to derive this equation.
And I've actually
done the derivation
for the sort of simple
case of Newtonian dynamics.
You actually see how trivially
the Lagrange equation
that is written here turns into
Newton's equation of motion
when you plug in for your
Lagrangian 1/2 nV squared
minus your potential energy.
And you see, when you take
the partial derivatives
of the Lagrangian with respect
to the generalized velocity,
since it is a
partial derivative,
you only need to
take the derivative
of the kinetic energy with
respect to the velocity,
with respect to x dot.
And then you need to
take partial derivatives
with respect to the position.
And there is no position in
the kinetic energy functional.
So there is only the position
in that potential energy.
So what you see is that,
from the left-hand term,
you have the
derivative with respect
to time of mass times velocity.
And so that's nothing else
than mass times acceleration.
And then on the right,
the right-hand term,
you have minus the gradient
of your conservative potential
field.
And so this is nothing
else than the force.
So we have force equal to
mass times acceleration.
And we have recovered.
Just by applying
Lagrange equations
to the Lagrangian of
classical dynamics, kinetics
minus potential, we have derived
Newton's equation of motion.
So this is one way of deriving
equation of motion, but, again,
are going to be
second-order differential
equation with respect to time.
Because, if you
think, you are taking
the derivative of a kinetic
energy with respect to q dot.
There is a second formulation
of classical mechanics--
and I also need to sort
of present this here--
that is called the
Hamiltonian formulation.
And it's sort of,
again, very easy
to see this if you think
of a thermodynamic analogy.
Say, when you're sort of
looking at thermodynamics,
suppose that you are in the
microcanonical ensemble.
Your thermodynamical
functional is the energy.
And so when you sort of look at
that thermodynamical ensemble,
it means that, say, you are
looking at the system that
has a constant energy,
constant number of particle,
and constant volume.
But many times it becomes
appropriate to look
at, actually, sort
of a system that
lives at constant pressure
or constant temperature.
And so you transform your
thermodynamical functional
from the energy to one, say,
of the Helmholtz or Gibbs
free energies.
You do e minus ds to obtain a
thermodynamic functional that
depends on temperature instead
of depending on entropy.
Or you do e plus pv to
obtain the enthalpy that
sort of depends on
pressure and not on volume.
And this is this general concept
of Legendre transformation.
If you have a
function, let's say,
for the Lagrangian was a
functional of q and q dot,
you can construct a new one that
doesn't depend, say, on q dot,
but depends only
on a new variable
that we call it the
conjugate variable 2q dot.
So pressure and volume,
temperature and entropy,
chemical potential and
number of particles
are all conjugate variables.
And so, say, if you take the
Lagrangian and you derive it
with respect to
q dot-- remember,
the Lagrangian is a
function of q dot--
what you obtain is
at conjugate variable
that we call a
conjugate momentum.
And then if you do this
operation, this Legendre
transform in which you take--
the sign doesn't really matter.
In this case, you
take a minus sign.
And you sum the product
of the conjugate variable
times your original variable.
You get a new function
that doesn't depend
on your original q dot
variable, but depends only
on its conjugate variable p.
That's how you remove the
dependence, say, on the volume
and you put in the
dependence on the pressure,
making the Legendre
transformation
which you have pv, or that's
how you sort of move on
from entropy to temperature
in the Helmholtz free energy.
And this is just
very simple to do
when you take the
differential of this quantity.
Because you are going
to see that really,
because of this relation,
you remove all the dependency
in q dot.
And you put into your
system an independence on p.
Well, why do we do this?
Well, because, again
with some algebra,
we can find that, for this
new function that is now
called the Hamiltonian,
another alternative
sets of equation of motions.
Remember, from
the Lagrangian, we
had obtained equation of motion
basically for q dot and q.
And from the
Hamiltonian formulation,
if we work this out, we
obtain equation of motion
for q and for p.
And sort of the
slight difference
is that instead of having
basically a second order
differential equation from the
Lagrangian formulation, now
we have a double
set of differential
that are only first-order.
So depending on
the your problem,
they can actually
be easier to solve.
They can actually be
different, but they could
lead to the same trajectories.
So again, all these formalisms
of Lagrangian and Hamiltonian
is that's the very general
way to construct functions,
either the Lagrangian T
minus V or the Hamiltonian
via the Legendre
transform that give us
equation of motion
in q and q dot
for the case of the
Lagrangian and in q and p
for the case of the Hamiltonian.
And if you actually
work this out
for the standard case
of Newtonian dynamics,
you find out that your
Hamiltonian is, again,
something very trivial.
It's just the kinetic energy
plus the potential energy.
So at the end of all of
this, for all the cases
of interest to you, you see
that either you construct
a Lagrangian T
minus V and you have
the Lagrangian
equation of motion,
or your construct your
Hamiltonian, p plus v.
And you have the sort of
Hamiltonian equation of motion
that I have written here.
And one of the reasons
that we do this--
so this is-- is that,
often, we want actually
to simulate the
microscopic dynamics
not in the
microcanonical ensemble,
but in different
thermodynamical ensembles,
say, in which we
control the temperature.
Or we control the
pressure, or maybe we
control the number of particles.
Or maybe we control
the chemical potential.
And so we need to have some
of this sort of formalism
to do this effectively.
In particular, remember when
we have discussed the sort
of control of temperature.
I've told you that
there are sort
of three different
approaches in which you
can do a canonical simulation,
which you can control
the temperature in your system.
And you could have
Langevin dynamics.
You could have a stochastic
approach in which you randomly
pick atoms in order
to accelerate them
or to slow them down.
So that in analogy
with a thermal bath,
they sort of, on average,
have the right kinetic target,
kinetic energy for your problem.
Or you could do something that
is probably even more brutal,
although it tends to be very
efficient in thermalizing,
effectively, your system.
You could actually do
a dynamics in which,
every time you have
got new position,
you renormalize those new
position by renormalizing
the velocity of the
particle, so that the sum
of the kinetic energy
is a actually constant.
So a constraint
method would actually
keep, strictly speaking, the
temperature of your system
sort of constant to
your target value.
That can be actually
very effective
to thermalize your
system, to bring
it really very close to your
equilibrium distribution.
But it does have
some counter-effects.
That is, if you
actually look at what
is going to be your equilibrium
distribution in positions,
it's really going to sort of
be a canonical distribution
according to the Boltzmann
canonical ensemble.
But if you look at your
distribution of velocity,
it's only pseudo-canonical.
So often, people,
especially those
that do very complex and
long molecular dynamics,
use the sort of most elegant
and most accurate approach.
That is really
coupling your system
to an additional
dynamical variable
using an extended Lagrangian
or an extended Hamiltonian.
So we have written our
Lagrangian or Hamiltonian
in terms of generalized
coordinates.
All of a sudden, you can add
one more generalized coordinate.
So you can add, if you
want, a pseudo-particle
in your system with its
own sort of kinetic energy
and with its own
potential energy.
And you can construct
the kinetic energy.
And in particular, you can
construct the potential energy,
so that this additional
dynamical system,
this additional dynamical
variable, interacts
with the other
dynamical variables,
basically exchanging
temperature with it
to bring the sort of
average temperature
of the real classical
particles to the equilibrium
distribution.
And so this is
actually how you would
write the extended
Lagrangian for the case
of a canonical
simulation, something
in which we want to keep
the temperature constant.
And so you see that's
where the power of all
this generalized
system comes into play.
And again, you sort of write
out your kinetic energy.
And note that there
is this sort of s
squared term that couples
the kinetic energy
of your real particles
with the kinetic energy
of this new thermostat,
as we call it.
So we have kinetic energy
minus potential energy.
And then this is
the new particle.
This is the new
extended coordinate
that is described by
a generalized position
s and the generalized
velocity s dot.
And so, if you want,
its kinetic energy
is written in a trivial way,
1/2 our generalized mass times
the square velocity.
And this is actually how Nos
figured out the potential
energy should look like for a
system of n classical particles
that you want to keep at an
inverse temperature beta.
Remember, beta is just 1 over
the Boltzmann constant times
the temperature.
And so it's a very
exotic potential energy.
And it's sort of the logarithm
of this generalized coordinate.
And so if you use
these Lagrangian,
you can construct the
Lagrangian equation of motion.
So you will have equation of
motion for your 3N particle
that will be very similar
to your standard equation
of motion, but we'll
have in there also terms
that contain s.
And then you will have a
sort of an equation of motion
for your Nos or Nos-Hoover
variable that is equation
of motion for s.
And you let all
this system evolve.
And what will happen is
that the kinetic energies
of your classical particles
will start to sort of distribute
themselves according to a
Maxwell-Boltzmann distribution.
That is according to
the canonical ensemble.
And people have worked out
all the statistical mechanics
of your problem
and so worked out
the appropriate coordination.
You would need to have a sort of
Maxwell-Boltzmann distribution.
This is in the moduli
of your system.
And really, if
you do all of this
and you sort of take an average
from your molecular dynamic
simulation, you really
see that both the position
and the velocity of
your classical particles
are distributed in
the appropriate way.
So it's very sort of useful
to calculate, say, response
suppose property of the system.
Say, again, if you want
to calculate the diffusion
coefficient from the
velocity-velocity
autocorrelation
function, you really
need to have your
velocity distributed
according to the appropriate
thermodynamical ensemble.
So it's sort of the, if you
want, most accurate and careful
way of doing the dynamics.
Nos-Hoover, so it's
probably the most common way
of thermostarting your problem.
It's not the most robust.
It's the approach that
gives you the long time
thermodynamical
properties correctly.
But it tends to be
very poorly, say,
for a system that
is very harmonic.
OK.
A system is very harmonic when
its potential energy is really
a quadratic function
of its coordinate.
So if you have, say,
a single particle
that sits in a
parabolic well, what
we call a harmonic
oscillator also
from a standard pendulum, that
is a perfect harmonic system.
A solid at very,
very low temperature
is also very harmonic.
If you want the potential
energy of each particle,
it's just a quadratic function
of the [INAUDIBLE] displacement
from its equilibrium position.
And so what are the trajectories
in a harmonic oscillator?
Well, they look
something like this.
If you look now, if you go back
to a one-dimensional position
and momentum
representation, well,
you know, a pendulum does
really this over and over again.
So this would be the
trajectory moving in time.
So the position sort of
oscillates back and forth.
And the momentum or the velocity
oscillate back and forth.
And they are in a
positional phase.
When the elongation is
maximum, your momentum
is linear and so on.
I actually sort of made,
I guess, incorrect axis.
But thanks to the power
of the [INAUDIBLE] tablet,
now this looks much better.
OK.
Now, suppose that
you sort of studying
not a single
oscillator, but you are
studying a solid at
very low temperature.
What your Nos-Hoover thermostat
would give you is something
that is very different from
the equilibrium distribution.
So the sort of equilibrium
canonical distribution
is going to look
something in which there's
of momenta and velocity of
the particle are distributed.
Because, now,
there is obviously,
if we have a real solid, a
small amount of interaction.
So each atom, each
harmonic oscillator,
is going to be talking
with its neighbors.
And so they are not going to
be all in phase and perpetually
in phase, but they are going
to sort of exchange energy
between one and the other.
And so a large harmonic
solid, but slightly
sort of different
from 0 temperature,
will have a distribution
of velocity and momentum
that doesn't sit in
a perfect circle,
but is sort of
distributed around.
If you do this with a
Nos-Hoover thermostat,
sadly there will be
no exchange of energy.
There will be no thermalization
between all different atoms.
They are going to
be doing perpetually
their own thing in synchrony.
And so the Nos-Hoover
thermostat works very poorly
for systems.
The more harmonic
your system is,
the poorer the equilibration
that comes from the Nos
thermostat is.
And so you have to
pay a lot of attention
to system at low temperature.
And sort of one of the usual
solutions that people mention
is using Nos-Hoover chains
in which you actually have
your dynamical system.
You have your thermostat.
And then you have
another thermostat,
thermostarting your
thermostart to thermostart
for your particle.
And then you have
a third thermostat
that thermostarts the
second thermostat.
And suddenly, you
have to do this.
Harmonic solids are
actually very important.
So there is a reason
why a lot of effort
has been put into this.
Because in particular--
and this is, again,
something that we'll see
in one of the last classes.
In order to calculate the
free energy of a system
at finite temperature,
often you need
to do an integration
from 0 temperature
to the present temperature.
And so you really need to
start from a harmonic solid
that you need to
describe correctly.
And if you don't
do that, so if you
don't use your proper
thermostating techniques,
this is not going to work out.
And there is really a
lot of dark [INAUDIBLE]
in all of this.
You really need to be careful
because the temperature is
a global quantity.
But if you have, say, a
system with 100 particles,
you can have a
temperature of 300 Kelvin
by having sort of all
particles distributed
along the same temperature.
But you can have also
the same temperature
if part of your system is very
cold and part of your system
is very hot.
And if you wanted,
the thermostat
has this role of making sure
that the energy flow goes
around, so that all
part of your system
are really at the equilibrium.
And you know, this can be
actually a trickier thing
than sort of it actually seems.
Obviously, all these
dots and [INAUDIBLE]..
OK.
These are sort of a
summary of all the books
in which you can find a
description of these concepts.
If you have to read
one for this class--
the sort of free primer
that Furio Ercolessi
has put on his website.
I'm actually very proud of this
because Furio moved recently
to this very small
town in northern Italy
that is sort of my hometown.
But anyhow, this is
available and free.
It's 30 or 40 pages.
I posted it also on
the Stella website.
And it gives you a
very clean introduction
to molecular dynamics.
And then I think this is a
field in which there are,
in particular, two
exemplary books.
So if you really want
to do this for a living,
there are a couple of books
that are very, very good--
the Allen and Tildesley book
that, by now, it's very old.
It's sort of really
written at the beginning
of the '80s when you can imagine
computer capabilities were
very different.
And it's actually
remarkable somehow how
the clarity that you develop
by dealing with systems that
are very primitive from the
computational point of view
actually develops your
intellectual skills.
So this is really
very, very good.
And equally good is a
much more recent book
that is in its third edition
from last year, the Frenkel
and Smit that also has
many more advanced topics.
But either of these
are really sort
of very, very good references.
And now, in the last
20 minutes, I'll
give you really the flavor
on how we do first principle
molecular dynamics.
That is really nothing else than
a classical molecular dynamics
with a lot of
additional variables.
So we use this concept
of extended Hamiltonians.
And you know, somehow it's,
by now, a little bit old.
I had sort of once
downloaded this.
This is actually the citations
of first principle molecular
dynamics, of initial molecular
dynamics or the citation
of the first paper that
developed this concept that
goes under the name of the
[INAUDIBLE] techniques that
is from 1985.
And you see we are sort
of very pleased with
this exponential explosion.
It means that basically there is
a lot of useless literature out
there that you can look at.
So in order to do first
principle molecular dynamics,
I need to give you a reminder
of your favorite topic.
That is the expansion in plane
waves of the total energy
of a system.
And hopefully, you still
remind something about this.
But if you have a
crystal that's going
to be defined by the three
primitive direct lattice
vectors--
so you could have an FCC crystal
and they point to 1/2, 1/2, 0,
0, 0, and the third one.
And then we can define
reciprocal space
and the reciprocal lattice whose
three primitive vectors, this g
vectors, are just defined as
the duals of your direct lattice
vector.
So the scalar total
between the reciprocals
and the direct lattice vectors
needs to be equal to 0 or 2 pi.
OK.
So this is the definition.
Once we have this
reciprocal lattice vectors
that, for simplicity,
I'll draw here
as being two-dimensional
and square, what we have is,
again, sort of these points here
represents all possible integer
combination of reciprocal
lattice vectors.
That, for my problem
at hand here,
say, this would be
the Brillouin zone.
This would be the unit cell
of the reciprocal lattice.
And so all these
g vectors in blue,
remember, are such that
the complex function e
to the iG times
r, where G is any
of these vectors represented
by one of these point,
this function in real
space is compatible
with your periodic
boundary condition.
It's going to have either one
oscillation inside your unit
cell, 2 oscillation, 3
oscillation, 10 oscillations.
And it's going to be, generally
speaking, in three dimensions.
And so if you remember, we
expand our wave function
into linear combination
of these plane waves
because these plane waves
are all the possible--
it's a complete set
of functions that
describe orbitals that
have the periodicity
of the direct lattice.
OK.
So what was our quantum
mechanical system?
We keep it simple.
We won't go into density
functional theory.
We'll just think
again at the operator.
You see the Hamiltonian
raises its head again.
It's just going to be the
quantum kinetic energy
minus 1/2 the Laplacian
plus the potential energy
and with the caveat
that we develop,
we expand, the periodic
part of your wave function,
what we call sort of, via the
Bloch theorem, the periodic.
Sometimes I call it u.
But what is the
periodic component?
We expand it.
We write it as a linear
combination of plane waves
with appropriate coefficients.
So if you want, your
quantum mechanical problem
is, yet again, nothing
else than trying
to find that these numbers.
Once you have defined
your basis sector,
then you have
written an expansion.
And then all your algebra and
all your computational problem
is finding out what this
coefficient should be.
And this tends to be a
very good basis sector
because it can be made more
and more accurate that by
including G vectors of
larger and larger models
that correspond to
plane waves of higher
and higher resolution.
Not only that, but it's actually
a very manageable basis sector
to use.
Because it's very easy to
take first derivatives,
second derivatives of a wave
function of square moduli.
Because, say, if we take a first
derivative of psi with respect
to r, the only thing that we
have is that each term in G
gets down from here
a factor i times G.
And the second
derivative gives us
a factor iG scalar product iG.
That is minus G squared.
OK.
So our quantum
mechanical problem basis
for our first principle
molecular dynamics
has really nothing else
to do than finding what
is the ground state energy.
That, not really in a
density functional formalism,
but in a sort of
simplified formalism,
I write out just as a
sum of the eigenvalues
of our single particle orbitals.
That is just the sum of all the
electrons of this expectation
value.
If you remember, in
density functional theory,
the energy is slightly different
because the Hamiltonian
in that approach has actually
become self-consistent.
The Hamiltonian depends on
the charge density itself.
And so there are some
additional collective terms.
But you know, from the point of
view of our sort of [INAUDIBLE]
here, it doesn't
really matter that we
include these additional terms.
And so, you know, what is that
we have to deal with here?
Well, we have, again, a
quantum kinetic energy term
and a potential energy term.
And so the quantum
kinetic energy
is going to be the sum of the
kinetic energy of each orbital,
as written here.
And you know what I
was saying before.
It's actually trivial to
calculate the kinetic energy
if you have a wave function
that is expanded in plane waves
because this is it.
This is the expectation value.
Remember, it's the integral
over all your Hilbert space.
That is the integral
in space of this.
This is the [INAUDIBLE].
So this is the complex
conjugate of the plane waves
e to the iGr.
So it's e to the minus
iGr times the action
of this operator to the plane
wave e to the iG prime r.
And so, you know, this
second derivative,
so with respect to
r, gives us an iG
prime times iG prime
that is a minus G square.
The minus sign cancels out.
And so we have 1/2 g square
times the integral with respect
to space of e to the minus
iGr times e to the iG prime r.
And actually, if G
is equal to G prime,
that is just going to be 1.
And so the integral,
it's actually--
I sort of skipped all
the normalization.
So the integral
is going to be 1.
You can work out the algebra.
If G is different from G
prime, it's going to be 0.
So this expectation value of
the kinetic energy operator
between two plane
waves is just going
to be 1/2 G square between
two identical plane waves.
And it's going to be 0 if the
plane waves are different.
This is what we say when we
say that the kinetic energy
operator in a matrix
representation in which
the rows and the columns are
the different plane waves
is actually diagonal.
That is, if you calculate this,
so you would have, say, G here
and G prime here, all the
terms in this matrix function
of G and G prime has 0
outside the diagonal.
And the diagonal is
1/2 G square, so very
trivial to do in plane waves.
If we want to calculate the
second term in the energy,
we need to calculate
the potential energy.
And the potential
energy is going to be,
again, sort of the sum over
all the single particle
terms in the potential energy.
And I'm doing the
same thing here.
I'm writing this expectation
value between two plane waves.
And so I have same as
before, the exponential
of the complex conjugate
minus iGr times e of r
times e to the iG prime r.
And if you look at this,
this is nothing else
than the definition
of the Fourier
transform coefficient of your
potential energy with respect
to the wave vector
G minus G prime.
So now, this part, the potential
energy in a plane wave basis
sector, is not anymore diagonal.
It's going to have
off-diagonal terms.
That is, if you look in
the previous sort of matrix
representation in G and G prime,
what we have along the diagonal
is just the kinetic energy
terms T that are 1/2 G squared.
But we are going to have
a number of diagonal terms
and also on-diagonal diagonal
terms from the potential.
Obviously, the more you
go outside the diagonal,
the more G minus G prime
is going to be large.
So the more you're going
to look at high frequency
components of your potential.
And in general,
unless your potential
is really ill-defined, the
high frequency components
are going to be
smaller and smaller.
So again, sort of the
overall Hamiltonian matrix
kinetic plus potential
in a plane wave basis
tends to be diagonally dominant.
As we move farther
and farther away,
it tends to be
smaller and smaller.
So we have actually
written all the terms.
And then we can take the sum
over all these expectation
value.
And so we have here
sort of a [INAUDIBLE],,
if you want, the total energy as
a function of this coefficient
of the plane waves.
So we have the kinetic energy
term and the potential energy
term.
And the fundamental approach
that we take in first principle
calculation is not trying to
diagonalize this Hamiltonian
to find eigenvalues
and eigenvectors
because that
operation would scale
as the cube of the
number of plane waves.
And it gives us not only the
10 or 20 lowest eigenvalues
that have the occupied states.
But, say, if we have a simple
system like the silicon atom--
remember, you have seen
semiconductors in your lab
two, where, at the
end, what you need
is really the four lowest
eigenvalues and the four lowest
eigenvectors.
Well, if you diagonalize
this Hamiltonian
and you have plane wave basis
set with 1,000 elements,
you get all 1,000
eigenvalues and eigenvectors.
We don't need that.
It's too expensive.
We need only 4 out of 1,000.
OK.
So the approach that most
or all electronic structure
approaches take is
actually an approach
in which we find what
are these coefficients
of the relevant
occupied orbitals.
You see, here, the
total energy, that's
the function of the
occupied orbital.
So for silicon,
we would sum only
on the four lowest orbitals.
And by minimizing
this quantity, we
find what are the coefficients.
So the electronic structure
problem, again, it's
a minimum problem in which
you have an expression
for the energy that, in
density functional theory,
is slightly more complex,
but at the end depends only
on the coefficients of
your plane wave expansion
and on the matrix elements of
the potential between plane
waves and of the kinetic
energy between plane waves.
You calculate these ones for
all or, in density functional
theory, at every step.
Because your potential,
being self-consistent,
changes up every time step.
But if you have this
and you have this,
it's nothing else than
a problem of finding
the minimum with respect
to these variables.
Sadly, you have sort
of thousands or tens
of thousands or hundreds
of thousands of them.
So it tends to be a
very expansive problem
of minimization of a
non-linear function that
depends on basically
zillions of variables.
So how do we do this?
Well, let's see.
We use a molecular
dynamics idea.
That is we have an energy,
a function of thousands
of variables.
So we have
multi-dimensional space
with really thousands
of coordinates.
And as a function of those
thousands of coordinates,
these c and G variables, what we
have is a total energy surface.
So our problem looks
nothing else like this.
We have a total energy
that is this sort
of hyper surface in black
that is non-linear functional
of these things.
In density functional
theory, for a standard LDA,
GGA calculation, this system
tends to have only one minimum.
If you are doing a spin
polarized calculation,
you will have
different minima that
corresponds to a
non-magnetic solution or all
the magnetic solution with
different set of values
for the magnetization.
Or maybe have
anti-ferromagnetic solution
with a total magnetization
of 0, but different
spins and so on and so forth.
So this potential
energy surface can
start to develop some
of the complex minima
that I was showing you
when we were talking
about simulated annealing.
And that's why actually
finding the ground
state of magnetic system tend to
become, very quickly, much more
complex.
In LDA or GGA, it
has only one minimum.
And we need to find that
minimum as a function
of this very many coordinates.
And so we use molecular
dynamics techniques
and molecular dynamic analogies.
And you know, I'll do
this in one dimension,
but really what we want to do
is find an equation of motion,
something that evolves
our coefficients, c, G,
so that they move
towards the minimum
of that potential
energy surface.
And in order to do that,
we have nothing else
to do than to calculate the
derivative of that Bloch
potential energy
surface with respect
to each and every variable, with
respect to each and every plane
wave coefficient.
Again-- sort of lots of algebra
that I'm hitting in there.
But actually, and
very pleasantly,
it's actually very simple.
And we sort of write
this generalized force.
That is the derivative
with the minus signs,
the gradient of the
energy with respect
to each and every coefficient.
And it's, by chance
and nothing else than,
the application of
the Hamiltonian itself
to the wave function
coefficient by coefficient.
And so it's actually sort
of very easy to calculate.
And then once we
have that, well,
so if we look at this
problem in one dimension,
what we have is our Bloch
potential energy surface.
And we need to find the minimum.
So this is the
energy as a function
of all this coefficient
of plane waves.
And we can choose a random
value for this coefficient,
calculate the energy.
And what we will have is
a value for this energy.
And now, what we want
is really to evolve,
to move the value of each
and every coefficient.
So that the total energy of
our system reaches the minimum.
And in order to do that,
we need the gradient
that we have written in the
previous expression that
is nothing than minus the
Hamiltonian applied to the wave
function.
That is the force.
And it's a perfect
dynamical analogy.
If you are somewhere
and you know
what is the force that
drives you downhill,
well, then you have
molecular dynamics techniques
to get to the bottom of your
potential energy surface.
And this is particularly
easy if, as in LDA or GGA,
your potential energy
surface has only one minimum.
And there are actually
two different approaches
that you could use.
You could use standard
molecular dynamics.
So if you are here, you
put yourself in motion.
And what you start
doing is going down.
But in a pure conservative
molecular dynamics,
you are going to
overshoot your minimum.
Go back and oscillate
perennially.
So what you do, you
actually put some friction,
so that you sort of
slowly lose energy.
And you basically,
again, condense down
to your sort of lowest
energy solution.
And so a standard molecular
dynamics technique
applied on the coefficient
of the plane waves
with a friction term
added is one approach that
brings all these additional
degrees of freedom of plane
waves down to the ground state.
This would be one approach.
The other approach would be
actually evolving your system
in a way in which the velocity
is proportional to the force.
And so, again, you
can think that, when
you are at the minimum,
your force is 0.
And so your velocity is 0.
And so if instead of
accelerating your system
proportionally to the force
and putting a friction that
is something that will oscillate
and dump down to the minimum,
you move with a velocity that
is proportional to your force.
It's something that, again,
it will sort of move you
towards the ground state.
Once you are here, your
driving force is going to be 0.
So your velocity
is going to be 0.
So somehow it's a
different approach
that also brings you to the 0.
And sort of the two approaches
have a slightly different
performance depending
on the kind of system
that you are doing.
In this case, in the
sort of dynamical way,
you need to make sure that
your friction is good enough.
That is you don't use
too much friction,
so you sort of flow down
and never reach the minimum.
And you have to
be sure that there
is sort of enough friction, so
you don't oscillate forever.
And that's one way in
this sort of approach
that you need to make sure
that your system, again,
doesn't really
sort of stop short
of getting to the minimum.
Because the closer you
get to the minimum,
the closer your
velocity is to 0.
And so you tend to just get very
close, but not right to there.
And there are
advanced techniques
to deal with both
of these systems.
And with this, I think
I'll actually conclude here
because I wanted to sort of tell
you more about how we actually
evolve in time this problem
when we start moving the atoms.
Up to now, we were sort of
thinking at just how to get out
at the ground state solution.
But then we have the
additional problem
of having the atoms
move, so our potential
starts changing in real time.
And we need to sort of
follow in real time what
happens to the solution.
And again, there are sort of
two general approaches that
go under the name of sort of
Born-Oppenheimer molecular
dynamics or sort of
Car-Parrinello molecular
dynamics.
And I think we'll leave
that at this stage for one
of the next lectures.
So let me just
sort of remind you
that another of the
terms that you'll
see for this kind of dynamics
in which the velocity drives
the system towards the
minimum goes actually
under the name of steepest
descent or conjugate gradient
minimization.
And that's, again,
a sort of technique
that you see very often
in minimization problem
where sort of this is really
a molecular dynamic kind
of simulated [INAUDIBLE].
With this, I conclude.
We'll keep some of the sort
of ab initio molecular dynamic
techniques for one
of the last lectures
when we actually go back and
look at case studies of this.
And in the last transparencies,
in the last few graph
of your notes, you have,
again, some freely available
bibliography of quantum
molecular dynamics
primers, in particular,
the sort of primer
of Dominik Marx on his website.
The last note is something
very completely and very well
written.
With this, I conclude.
Have a very happy weekend,
and we'll see you on Tuesday
in the lab in 115.